buenas tardes me ayudan leyendo este
pensamiento por favor cada uno en su
silla internamente
bueno qué es lo que a mí este
pensamiento o como lo interpreto yo
básicamente es que sin guamazos y sin
madrazos no hay evolución y la evolución
duele y duele mucho hay desafíos en la
vida que o golpes los madrazos que la
vida te pone y hay otros que tú decides
y de eso les quiero platicar el día de
hoy mi familia nuclear está compuesta
por cuatro personas mi mamá que siempre
me acompaña una mujer muy positiva muy
alegre y sobre todo muy dedicada a la
educación de sus hijas mi hermana
carolina que es nueve años más chica que
yo llegó a revolucionar la familia a
cambiar la dinámica familiar y mi papá
un hombre muy luchador que le he puesto
bastante salir adelante tuvo una
historia muy fuerte empezar a estudiar
ya trabajar desde muy joven para
mantener a su familia y eso lo hizo
tener un carácter muy muy muy fuerte era
una educación muy férrea muy estricta
pero siempre impulsándonos a que
saliéramos adelante y que fuéramos
personas de bien mi hermana y yo todo
este trabajo tal
tan determinante y todo este actividad
que llevaba como nunca lo hizo ser un
hombre muy estresado muy nervioso y por
lo mismo de de su carácter empezó a
desarrollar padecimientos de salud pues
un poco complicados y les quiero
platicar un poco de esta vía crucis que
empezamos a vivir en diciembre del 2009
planeo mi papá un viaje que tenía una
ilusión muy fuerte de hacerlo y quería
conocer hacia en ese entonces ya
empezaba a tener un problema de riñón y
con toda la ilusión del mundo él
organizó con mucha antelación y
prácticamente unos días antes de irnos
empieza con una gripa un poco fuerte le
dijimos ya no hay que pensar el viaje
nos quedamos aquí y él estaba es mi
ilusión quiero ir ya ya está todo pagado
vámonos por favor y ahí ya veremos qué
pasa entonces nos fuimos hasta el otro
lado del mundo
en un crucero
y llegamos al barco y nos reparten las
habitaciones llegamos a la habitación
que nos tocaba mi hermana y a mí y
prácticamente estaba al lado del cuarto
de máquinas siempre nos dan impresión
cuando lo vimos porque la única
ventanita chiquita que tenía
prácticamente estaba
abajo del agua y ese día yo no sé en qué
posición de del cuarto del barco
estábamos que era un cruce de mares del
mar chino y japonés y era un movimiento
espantoso la pasamos muy muy mal esa
noche las cámaras se movían hasta
realmente era
no era fácil dormir y al día siguiente
nos vamos a la recepción y le decimos a
la señorita por favor si tiene algún
otro cuarto aunque sea un piso más
arriba aunque esté en la punta o atrás
para no marear nos tanto se lo vamos a
agradecer nos dice el barco viene
absolutamente lleno pero este este barco
normalmente vienen personas adultas
mayores
y en ocasiones se enferman y se bajan ya
lo veamos medio complicado ironías de la
vida a los dos días nos bajamos nosotros
la gripa de mi papá se convirtió en una
neumonía y el capitán decidió bajarnos
en el siguiente puerto estuvimos en
total tres noches ahí en el crucero
bajamos en el puerto de hong kong a las
tres y mi papá en una ambulancia
llegamos a un hospital público enorme y
no sabíamos que iba a proceder salen por
fin los doctores con un muy mal inglés
era muy complejo comprender les lo único
que nos decía es que estudiábamos
preparadas porque lo más probable es que
no fuera pasar la noche que estaba en
riesgo de una muerte súbita entonces
para nosotros estar del otro lado del
mundo son las conesa
bueno pues con esa nueva noticia pues sí
fue bastante y además será navidad era
el 24 ptos años fuimos las 3 tristísimas
en la calle a ver qué que sucedía para
resumir esta historia nos quedamos dos
meses en hong kong él estuvo un mes en
terapia intensiva con hemodiálisis y al
siguiente mes lo lograron sacar adelante
excelentes médicos en un excelente
hospital pero era público para los de
hong kong para nosotros evidentemente no
pues bueno fue toda una situación
compleja incluso con el seguro
regresamos a querétaro
pues como el ave fénix resurgió en mi
papá y tomó una vitalidad impresionante
regreso al trabajo con una enjundia muy
fuerte y al año y medio después una
américa un medicamento mal administrado
lo vuelve a mandar a terapia intensiva
dos semanas aquí en querétaro estamos
muy pegadas a él siempre fue una
relación
pues muy unidos estuvimos dos semanas
sin despegar nos y nuevamente como el
ave fénix impresionante parecía gato de
nueve vidas y otra vez iba para adelante
con una vitalidad y una fortaleza
impresionante admirable pero el día dijo
ya me siento más cansado y esto o sea ya
no puedo estar con las hemodiálisis se
hacía y empezó con una diálisis
peritoneal que es aquí por el estómago
donde te sacan el líquido sí y te
vuelven ingresar líquido nuevo para
limpiarte en la sangre
entonces dijo necesito someterme a un
trasplante de riñón porque quiero volver
por lo menos a tomar agua no cuando
tienes insuficiencia renal no puedes
tomar agua por ver tomar agua poder
viajar poder gozar las y poder disfrutar
nosotros estábamos muy nerviosas porque
es someterse una operación él tenía 68
años no era muy grande pero bueno
también el riesgo siempre que haya
alguno de tus familiares se someta a una
operación y año y medio después
conseguimos un donante que por voluntad
propia decidió darle su riñón
y la operación fue en octubre del 2012
fue una operación exitosa y al finalizar
sus estudios daban pues resultados como
de un joven de 30 años que estamos todos
muy muy felices de que había sido que
pues por fin está toda esta pesadilla de
estos años había terminado y el 2 de
diciembre del 2012 en su cuerpo ya no
resistió y decidió retirarse en la
convención se cambió de domicilio como
decimos ni nada y un lugar donde ya no
lo puedes volver a ver y esperemos que
sí que esté bien pero por lo menos
cumplió lo que él decía en un simio pero
y estoy bien podré tomar y si no pues ya
me voy a descansar y finalmente el 2 de
diciembre descansa y bueno pues se
imaginarán probablemente alguien de aquí
haya experimentado una situación similar
el fallecimiento de un familiar y si
entenderán lo duro y lo fuerte y
horrible que es sentirte totalmente sola
en ese tema y más cuando es un papá en
ese momento llegó una muy buena noticia
para nuestra vida y por lo menos nos
hizo volver a sonreír decidimos casarnos
en ese entonces mi novio pablillo en
2013 y bueno por primera vez después de
muchos meses de estar muy tristes
volvimos a sonreír y hoy por hoy les
puedo decir que ha sido la mayor
bendición siempre lo digo que no ha
pasado y mi mayor generador de
conciencia siempre se lo digo siempre me
regaña y luego me enojo pero siempre se
lo agradezco y bueno pues teníamos que
regresar la vida sigue la vida no se
para y el mundo no deja de girar aunque
tú quieras que se detenga pues la vida
de los demás continúa y pues nosotros
tenemos que seguir trabajando en la
empresa de mi papá poner una empresa que
él fundó en el año 2000 como único dueño
y pues era nuestro principal ingreso es
una empresa dedicada al sector de la
construcción y bueno pues teníamos que
entrar aviso en ese momento era una
vulnerabilidad y una soledad espantosa
la que sentíamos nosotras tres por qué
no sabíamos ni siquiera qué hacer con la
empresa evidentemente yo no tenía idea
de ingeniería y todo mundo a nuestro
alrededor nos decía que vendiéramos la
empresa porque aquí vamos a hacer tres
mujeres solas en un negocio tan
complicado tan hostil y tan difícil y
sobre todo el liderado por hombres y sí
sí es muy hostil por supuesto que si es
si es muy complicado pero bueno
finalmente no había otra opción más que
nosotras entrar a la empresa y ahora ya
dentro de la empresa cuando yo trataba
de acercarme hay un rechazo absoluto y
tenían toda la razón yo no tenía ni la
más remota idea de cómo llevar una
empresa en una empresa jamás había
tenido una empresa y ahora siempre había
sido colaboradora entonces no no no
tenía esa experiencia ni sabía lo que me
iba enfrenta entonces un rechazo
absoluto de que llegara yo a llevar una
empresa tan complicada y tan difícil
y fuera todo mundo nos decían no van a
poder estar ya vendan las deshagan se
mejor dedíquense a estar tranquilas y yo
al principio decían bueno pues si está
muy complicado pues igual si tienen
razón qué vamos a hacer y después era
tanto lo que me decían es que no van a
poder no van a poder ya ven vendan este
pobrecita será como demasiado el tema
negativo que ese tema me dio tanto
coraje que me dijeron por qué me están
juzgando si ni siquiera saben si soy
capaz de hacer algo y ese coraje se
convirtió en un reto personal dije ahora
si van al con seguridad poder
no sé qué voy a hacer pero sí voy a
poder y así es como les digo a la
empresa esto es lo que va a pasar yo voy
a llegar a dirigir vamos a ver qué
sucede y luego venía pues otro golpe en
la vida era que empezaron a cerrar
nuestro dar las puertas
nadie quería darle trabajo a una empresa
donde el hombre clave ya no estaba y
quedaba una mujer sin experiencia sin
conocimiento absolutamente de nada
entonces todas las puertas empezaron a
cerrar no teníamos un solo contrato
en puerta entonces ahí empezaba a venir
todavía un problema más fuerte porque
había deudas había nóminas que pagar y
bueno la situación se empezaba a
complicar aún una vez más se volvió así
tanto el tema que reunía a todos los
colaboradores y les dije a ver no tengo
idea de lo que ustedes hacen se lo
reconozco pero si siguen diciendo que
vamos a quebrar y que yo no voy a poder
pues efectivamente va a pasar
ya pónganse las pilas y ayúdenme por
favor a sacar adelante esta empresa
denme una oportunidad lo único que yo
les pido ya mi mamá le dije lo mismo
dame una oportunidad no la vamos a y no
hay que venderla dame dos años en lo que
yo me preparo y aprendo a ser la líder
que necesitan mis colaboradores para que
me sigan hasta donde los quiero llevar
entonces empieza un tema muy muy
profundo y muy interesante donde yo
tengo que empezar a romper muchas
creencias y muchos paradigmas y adentro
y afuera seguía una resistencia muy
profunda y les pedí que me ayudaran a
entender qué es lo que hacía cada uno de
ellos
empieza un proceso de mucho estudio de
lectura de diplomados fuertemente para
poder dirigir una empresa y en alguno de
esos clases o en algún concepto no
recuerdo bien ve un caso nos presenta en
el caso de cirque du soleil que decía
que ese circo tenía muchas más filas de
personas que querían entrar que broadway
pagando todavía un sueldo mucho menor y
que la razón de por la que querían estar
dentro de la empresa era porque les daba
un sentimiento de pertenencia y de
comunidad muy fuerte y sobre todo el
prestigio que les daba haber estado en
una empresa de ese nivel es cuando y
toda esa historia dije eso es justo lo
que yo quiero que pase
enagás él quiero hacer un cambio con
totalmente radical de la cultura
organizacional ya no está el líder pero
vamos a resurgir ahora en un trabajo en
equipo todos juntos vamos a sacar
adelante esta empresa se va a convertir
en un lugar donde muchas muchas personas
quieran trabajar y donde sientan un gran
orgullo de estar
bajando y así es como volvemos a
reunirnos todos y pedimos descubrir
nuestra nueva misión cuál era la nueva
misión de la empresa mi papá siempre
tenía dos frases que decía
constantemente y él siempre decía el
único límite que existe es el que tú
mismo te impones era muy positivo y la
segunda decía el fin del ser humano es
propagar bienestar y eso se me quedó muy
grabado dijiste es este es el propósito
donde yo tengo que llevar a la empresa y
es así como entre todos los
colaboradores sacamos la misión de la
empresa que es nosotros generamos
bienestar construyendo caminos que
conducen una mejor calidad de vida para
todos los que trabajan ahí y todo el
impacto que tengamos hacia afuera
esa misión está sostenida por cuatro
grandes valores que también descubrimos
nosotros y es un entusiasta respeto por
las personas compromiso de servicio
insuperable guerreros de la calidad
integridad que trasciende para que ellos
me pudieran seguir yo tenía que ser muy
congruente precisamente con esa misión y
con esos valores para que me pudieran
seguir
tenían que ver el ejemplo reflejado en
mí y así es que como después de mucho
esfuerzo y mucho trabajo empezamos a
girar esa rueda de la grava a cambio de
la cultura organizacional primero empecé
sola seguía un rechazo fuerte hasta que
poco a poco de manera muy humilde
empezar con cada uno de ellos a que me
conocieran en una manera más personal y
empezaron a vislumbrar la misma visión
que yo traía para la empresa y así es
como generamos un equipo de alto
desempeño con gran talento de personas
desaparecidos el departamento de
recursos humanos porque no me gusta la
palabra recurso no somos un recurso
somos un grupo de seres humanos con
grandes talentos y capacidades que si
nos juntamos podemos lograr resultados
de verdadero valor y en lugar de la
oficina de recursos humanos se quedó la
gerencia de la felicidad porque yo
estaba con toda la disposición que todas
las personas que colaboraban enagás él
fueran plenas felices se desarrollaran y
además tuvieran un impacto
afuera más allá y generamos en esa
oficina un programa muy ambicioso
increíble que se llama hagas el 3d donde
nos dedicamos a empoderar al colaborador
desde sus tres dimensiones fundamentales
la personal
tu impacto como colaborador dentro de la
empresa y tu impacto en la sociedad se
tienen que hacer pruebas exámenes
lectura asistencia a eventos culturales
tenemos un departamento de wellness
donde se atienden nutrición deporte
psicología porque para mí era muy
importante que ellos estuvieran bien
estuvieran con una autoestima alta para
que entonces si pudiéramos imponer todo
el orden y todo el talento que teníamos
como equipo ahí en enagás él y así es
cómo sale surge hágase el 3-d
un programa que año con año seguimos
mejorando no por supuesto a prueba y
error y en ese entonces también pues yo
tenía que seguir haciéndome visible
porque necesitábamos clientes no
acuérdense que todas las puertas estaban
totalmente cerradas y bueno pues así es
como ingresó yo algunos organismos
empresariales como el caso de coparmex
donde esos valores que tenían en el
organismo para mí eran muy
significativos siempre hablaban de más y
mejores empresas con un alto sentido de
responsabilidad social además de eso
quería aprender quería conocer a
empresarios exitosos y talentosos
necesitaba aprender a ser empresaria y
por supuesto también
hacerles ver que la empresa seguía viva
y que si teníamos trabajo y que además
íbamos a hacer las cosas bien y que
estábamos haciendo todo un cambio
cultural muy fuerte que íbamos en serio
pero hoy por hoy les puedo decir que
esto si funcione que funciona muy bien
tenemos ya por segundo año consecutivo
la certificación the great place to work
también la mención honorífica anyway
como un programa de desarrollo humano
muy innovador y de un alto impacto
social sobre todo lo que me da más gusto
es que tenemos en las empresas de
construcción las rotaciones alrededor de
un 30 40 hasta un 50 por ciento
nosotros tenemos abajo del 2 por ciento
la rotación en la empresa entonces eso a
mí me hace saber que las personas están
gracias
eso a mí me hace saber que las personas
tienen la camiseta bien puesta y que
realmente estamos caminando hacia la
misma visión que les plantea desde un
inicio y otro el que más orgullo me da
es que hoy por hoy después de hacer una
empresa totalmente compuesta
prácticamente por hombres hoy los
puestos más importantes de la empresa no
ocupados por mujeres jóvenes entre 23 y
24 años
gracias
hoy 40 me les puedo decir que sé que más
desafíos van a venir estoy segura que
unos van a ser duros también estoy
segura un poco recordando lo que decía
el pensamiento al inicio es que cuando
pasen esos desafíos
hay que tener la voluntad de voltear a
ver hacia nosotros hacer una
introspección buscar recursos y
herramientas que no sabíamos que aún
tenemos y resurgir como el sol aún más
fuerte aún más fuerte y buscar fuerza
interior su desigual ward a reiterar los
madrazos y los golpes de la vida te
hacen evolucionar
finalmente preguntarles a todos ustedes
en qué golpe en que me abrazan qué reto
se dieron cuenta que eran fuertes muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]